hello my name is Sabina Fisher and I'm a
postdoctoral researcher at the
university of frankfurt and during my
work i use mathematical methods to
figure out cellular processes in my talk
I will show you how we use Mathematica
to build an image and data analysis
pipeline and how we applied it to
analyze cell packing in three
dimensional cellular aggregates
hi there we are going to start our in
the next presentation from Sabine Fisher
and her presentation is called
Mathematica in cell biology image
segmentation and analysis of 3d tumors
roy's thank you thank you for coming to
my presentation I'm gonna tell you a
good about how we use Mathematica to do
research and cell biology so to
understand cell biological processes a
bit more I'm a postdoc in at the good
university here in Frankfurt and I'm
part of the physical biology group and
the great thing that I love about this
group is that we are very heterogeneous
group so we have people from all sorts
of disciplines we have biologists
chemists physicists mathematicians
bioinformaticians
everything almost you can think of it in
Natural Sciences and we're part of the
biological science department and what
we do is we look at cell and
developmental biology we do quite a lot
of microscopy also microscopy
development and then of course we need
to do data processing and try to do
quantitative analysis and essentially
what our idea is that that we try with
the whole group we try to match this
whole circle so everyone of course needs
a scientific challenge to start with but
then we have the methods development for
example the microscopy development we
have the experiments the traditional
ones you've done by the biologists and
then and that's why it's called physical
biology group we really want to do
quantitative analysis of our data and
this is where I come in and this is also
what I'm going to tell you about today
so these part down here the data
acquisition
more or less the data processing data
analysis and then and some of our
questions we also do some mathematical
modeling but I'm not going to talk about
this today and then of course you need
to reconsider go back to your scientific
question of the whole cycle starts again
okay so what's the scientific question
for today what I'm going to tell you
about this multicellular spheroids so
these are three dimensional cell
clusters and they essentially form you
put the cells in a well and then they
aggregate and form 3d classes and this
is what you'll see in the movie here so
on the left you see the wide field image
on the right hand side you see the
fluorescence image where we've tagged uh
cell nuclei and essentially what you
what we look at we look at the well from
the bottom and we see how the cells come
together and then you see because it's
just a 2d image if it gets more and more
blurry that's when the cells go in 3d
and you end up with a real proper 3d
ball and I'll show you what this looks
like in the next slide so here
we'll see I'm just gonna pause that for
a minute so here at the bottom we see
this is our 3d spheroid imaged with 3d
microscope and we've just cut out a bit
to demonstrate what it looks like and on
the top you see one slide out of this
the spheroid and spheroids are very
popular models for tissue studies and
also tumor studies so in this case it's
the spheroid is formed of tumor cells
and why are they so popular is because
they resembled typical features that you
see in tissues so in this slide here we
see that that we can we have three
different zones in the middle here also
you can see down on this image here the
cells die there's a necrotic zone
because this fear this fear it is rather
big so in nutrients like oxygen can't
get in then here we have a quiescent
zone where the cells essentially just
sit they don't do much and out here we
have cell division going on so we have
quite a good representation of an a
vascular tumor
so it's humor that where you don't have
vasculature yet
and this is why they're very popular to
sort of start a study for example drugs
because and in former times what people
used to do is they do it to the cell
culture so you have like a glass dish
and you put the cells in and then you
test your drugs but we are not three
demand and not to dementia we have three
or dimensional's so and people have
found out that to actually study cell
interactions in 3d that you get
different results and you also get
different results from the drug testing
if you do it on 3ds spirits and set of
these 2d tissues okay so so far what
most people do is they have the spheroid
and then they put it on put a truck on
it and they see whether it shrinks or
not they just look at it in a 2d from
the top and and then they look if the
diameter shrinks or not but with our
fantastic microscope if you look at the
image here on the side then you see
these individual points and these are
the cell nuclei and if I let it run
again and you can see it we can image
the nuclei through the whole spirit and
so we have the opportunity that we can
actually measure what the individual
cell does in these spirits which most
people can't so our goal what we want to
do is we want to use these spirits to
analyze the drug effects not just on the
whole spirit but really on individual
cells and for that what we need is an
image and a data analysis pipeline
because we need to be able to
automatically detect the cell nuclei and
see what what their distribution is
within the spheroid because with these
ones they have I don't know thirty-five
thousand cells so you really don't want
to do that manually you don't want to
click on every single nucleus and this
is what I'm going to tell you about
today I'm going to tell you about the
data analysis pipeline that we've pulled
up and I'm going to show you one brief
result for them okay now the problem is
of course Mathematica has all these
nicely built and functions for image
analysis and one of them is that you
just do a binarize ation so you do a
global thresholding every pixel that is
above a certain value is its foreground
and the rest is background if we do that
on our spirit then we get really densely
packed clusters so here we
from the image on the right we see that
different components that belong
together they have the same color and we
can already judge that here for example
this area that is more than one
component you can see it it must be
three but this just simple segmentation
doesn't really work so we'll have to
come up with something better so what
we've developed is this
three-dimensional sound nuclear
segmentation pipeline let's say approach
where we combine two different ways so
we start this is our image stack that
I've showed you earlier where we just go
to slice by slice through the 3d volume
we can put it together into a 3d volume
and we use image 3d and Mathematica for
that and then we do two things one thing
is we do this binarization as I told you
in the slide before so you detect
foreground and background pixels but
what we also do is to split up the ones
that are clustered together we find
seeds within the within the different
components or seeds should represent
different points and they should each
seed should represent one nucleus and
then we can use the seeds together with
the binary image and then we get a
components image where we where we have
them all separated and out of that we
can extract the features so I'm going to
tell you but more in detail and I'm
starting with the with the binarization
so what we do we we don't quite do the
the global binarization that i've just
talked about what we use it the local
adaptive binarization they've they've
implemented that recently and it's quite
useful you don't do a global one anymore
you
it essentially separates the image into
individual parts and then it does the
binarization on every single part so if
you have variations and local intensity
those are match so so it's it's adjusted
to that and this is essentially now one
problem of the local adaptive binarize
is that if you do it in 3d it still runs
forever so what we've decided to do is
we do it in 2d along the different axis
and then we put the picture together so
we sort of
method over all the slides and this is
what this three-way local adaptive
binary sphere essentially does so here
we have it three times one two three and
then we put the image back together and
that works quite nicely so here I can
show you an example on how how it works
on a stack and so here we see the the 2d
slices and on the right hand side here
we see the outlines of the cell nuclei
that it has detected so if we look at
long this axis it all looks very good we
can already see that it's recognized the
images very well however if we put it
all together and show there's a 3d image
we see this and remember one color is
one object so here all the cell nuclei
they are all still clustered together
so what it's done nicely it has nicely
separated the spheroid from the
background but it wasn't very good at
separating the objects and if we look at
that in detail I'm just gonna give you
three examples so here are clusters that
I just clustered together so here we
have two nuclei three nuclei for this is
a whole cluster and that is just one
object at the moment so so far this this
doesn't quite do what we want we still
need to separate our clusters and what
we do is we use a seated 3d watershed so
as I said we use seeds to identify where
cell nucleus should be and then for
example if we look at this cluster here
what we will get us will get three
positions and out from these three
positions you have sort of like water
spreading this is what the water should
I agree rhythm does you have the water
spreading and it will spread from this
region outwards from this region
outwards and then where they meet sort
of these water basins that's where you
get the separation between the objects
so but first of all we need the seeds so
for the seeds what we use is we use the
lab fashioned of caution filter it's
again a function that is implemented
into Mathematica but we don't use it
just in this simple way because that
that doesn't quite do the trick what we
do is we use it at different scale
so you think of a Gaussian filter it
usually filters the image by taking sort
of the looking at the image the the
pixel values in a certain region or the
walks of areas in a certain region of
around the voxel and then computing the
new pixel from that and this is what the
what is meant by the scale so for the
laplacian of gaussian filter here this
is again our function to to detect the
blobs what we do is the the main part is
here we use a map and we do that over a
certain range of scales and then in here
we use our laplacian of gaussian filter
and this is where we use the scale so if
you have a smaller scale you will detect
smaller features in your image and if
you have a larger scale then you will
sort of detect larger blobs it's a bit
like zooming in and out on an on an
image using these different scales and
then these other parts they these parts
here they sort of just they take the the
voxels and look at which scale you get
the highest response from your lab
Taschen filter and that's probably the
the part where you have the blob and if
you do this we do that on our example
image that I showed you earlier then
this is where we get the seeds now after
you later Deneuve it but they are
usually smaller but so that you can see
them on the screen
I've enhanced them a bit and we can see
that we get nice positioning of the of
the seeds on the individual cell nuclei
and if we look at it in 3d then here we
have have this nice sort of cloud of
points essentially so this is gives us
just the position of our and okay it
doesn't give us the volume or the
extension yet so to get the extension or
we then combine the seeds with a 3d
watershed so as I explained already it's
sort of you drop water where the Cetus
and then it expands and that will give
you the regions of the nuclei and this
is the result for our example image
and now we see that we have the nuclei
nicely separated so we have the whole
areas or in this case 3d the volumes and
if I go through the slides we can see
that each each color represents a
nucleus and and it matches the original
one quite well and compared to earlier
if we then look at it in 3d we also see
that we have the individual nuclei now
not just the whole blob in one color and
just to visualize it a bit more I'm
going to show you my examples from
earlier so these were the ones they were
all combined together and now we have
two nuclei here this one's also nicely
separated here we have our big cluster
again that worked rather well and there
we have the fourth example so there you
can also see you spread out from here
and then this is where the two water
basins sort of meet and this is where
you get the separation okay so now we
know where our cell nuclei are we know
which voxel belongs to which nucleus and
so we've basically finished the
segmentation and we can now move on to
extract the features and of course first
of all there's the built-in function
from Mathematica the component
measurement and there we already get
quite a lot of long list of things out
there that we want and we we save it in
this sort of option format because then
it's easier to process it later on
that's the funny thing okay so for
example we get the label we get the
centroid the count here is the volume
intensity centroid different measures of
the intensity but there are other things
that we would like to know for our for
our purposes one thing for example that
we want to know is does the that's the
the property of a cell nucleus does it
depend on where it is in the spheroid so
what we do is of course for the
spheroids we only have the cell nuclei
so we don't really have like the whole
boundary of the spheroid so what we use
is we use the spherical harmonic so
we've heard them earlier today some of
maybe here we use them in a completely
different context so the idea is that to
to use the spherical harmonics sort of
as building blocks like LEGO pieces
maybe to approximate the surface of our
3d spheroid and some people have have
actually done it but extensively they've
tried to rebuild the to approximate the
head of max-planck with the with the
spheroid of the spherical harmonics and
what we see here is you have them in
different orders so that's you use
that's essentially the building blocks
you use if you have higher order use
more building blocks and you also get
more details so here they've used an
order of two and then twenty and fifty
where they get really precise detail of
course for our purposes the twenty and
fifty that will only give us artifacts
because our viewers are rather round so
we might want something that's close to
an ellipse maybe so to use these we use
our positions of our cell nuclei so this
is what we do here centroid and then we
can just use the replace that's the nice
thing about having those rules that I
said earlier okay and then we can can
plot them and we have this whole cloud
of thing but to actually use the
spherical harmonic approximation we only
need the surface points so we don't want
the whole cloud we want the surface of
it and this is where I'm going to show
one example of how to get a mesh and I'm
going to show you a different example
later on and this is sort of the older
version so one thing that Mathematica
has burden is this tet-chan link so it's
essentially a link to an external
program that they found might be useful
and it's called this tetrahedral mesh
generator and it was developed at this
Institute in Berlin and with this tetran
we can generate a convex hull of course
with the new region functions for
Mathematica can probably do that now
with the Mathematica built-in functions
but when I did this they they didn't
have them yet and from this we can
extract the surface points and then we
can plot the surface points and we see
that here this is
this is just the surface and now we can
use the spherical harmonic functions as
before
and as my colleague said this morning
the problem is they are they're not real
function so I'll have to adapt them a
bit so that I get a real surface and I
do I can do all these calculations and
then I can plot them and here we've
chosen order of three which is sort of a
sensible value for our purposes and this
is now our point cloud with the surface
build on top of it and we see it fits it
very nicely
so now we we have ideas about the whole
spheroid and we can measure things in
this whole sphere so we can measure the
centroid for example other things so
what I what I usually do is I don't
choose one order but I choose I've
chosen from order one to order seven and
then I I look at which one's the most
appropriate so here I have the the
approximation vector and also the
approximation error for orders from one
to seven and I can also then calculate
the volume of course of my spirit which
I couldn't before and once I have this
approximation of the surface I can then
say more things about my nucleus because
then for each nucleus I can say where is
it in terms of distance to the to the
surface of this fjord
so and this is what we essentially add
to our list so again this is our example
nucleus of course we will have that like
thirty five thousand entries for that
but this is just one example and to all
the measures that we had before here's
the intensity we now at the surface
point so here we have chosen order three
is the best for that example case or a
three or four and there we have a
surface point and we also have a
distance to the surface so now we can
have a better idea of where each nucleus
is in our spheroid and then what we're
really interested in is how many how
well are these how are these cells
packed so how many neighbors do they
have what is the distance to their
neighbor
and one good approximation of which
cells are next to each other is a vue
sur de l'année triangulation so the
learning edge gives you triangulation
where you have the interior angle is
maximized and it's usually as so many
people use it to describe neighbor ship
relations between cells it's a very
popular method for that and has been
shown regularly that that that works
quite well and this is now where I'm
showing you the second version of how
you can get a mesh because now I'm
actually using the the Mathematica
built-in functions mesh the nominee mesh
and then we can extract so here we can
generate the mesh from our coordinates
this is again our coordinates with the
centroids and then we can extract the
lines from it here with this command
mesh cells and this is what would give
you the image on the left and there we
see that particularly maybe here we have
still quite long distances or we have
some some of these lines they are
actually spanning over several this one
here it spans over this cell so this is
not what we would call a neighbor if you
look at it with your eye so what we then
did is we we actually deleted all of
those lines that were longer than than
30 pixels in our case which is which is
sort of a reasonable distance within our
sizes of cells and then we get the
picture on the right and that looks much
more reasonable
so here the the red parts our cell
nuclei so it's just the positions and
I've put a sphere there and then the the
white ones are the connecting lines and
with this knowledge we can then update
again our list of measurements for our
nuclei and this is what I've done here
so we append the neighbors and this is
where we determine the neighbors these
these are all the functions that do it
but essentially here at the bottom is
where we get the results and I'm just
going to add a few lines around
better visible so here we had our
distances and now we can count the
neighbors so we can count how many white
lines go out of one of those red dots
and we can look at the distances to the
neighbors and we can also look at the
standard deviation once we have all
these measurements what we do is we save
them in an in a notebook so we create a
report and I'm just going to quickly do
this here so here we we use create
document and then we have a text cell
and then we essentially plot all our
functions into a notebook all our
results and then we can save the
notebook and this is what it will then
look like so we have a title and we have
the date so it's just been generated and
here I've just plotted three parts just
for one one example but essentially we
then have all the plots for all the
different data sets and we can go
through them and we can check and this
is this is without formatting this is
just the raw data so that we can look at
it and check which one has interesting
features which ones do we want to look
at further is there anything that that
doesn't look like we would imagine it to
and then we'd have to go back to the
images and see if something went wrong
so it's a result but also to check
whether everything was okay and then out
of these results we can then choose the
the most interesting ones and plot them
and I'm giving you one example here so
we what we the two functions we're using
here is the density histogram and the
error bar plots and what we want to look
at is we have these two data sets and in
one we found twenty-five thousand cells
and then the other one we found 35,000
cells and you can see by I already that
the structures look somehow different so
we have the impression that depending on
the cell number you get differences of
cell packing so here you have a much
larger necrotic zone
and this is what we've plotted here with
the density histogram so we've plotted
the we have the distance to the surface
and we've normalized it so at zero is
right next to the surface at 1 is in the
center and then we have the number of
neighbors and the color gives us how
many percent of cells have that number
of neighbors and we can see here is
quite a high number of cells with about
15 neighbors which what is what we would
expect from sort of a hexagonal packing
but in this area we can also see that
here is sort of an extra peak that we
don't have here where we have more cells
that have less neighbors and this is
what we would imagine from this image as
well and if we use arrow bar plots
instead then this and plot the function
as as it is here and again we have the
distance from the surface so here's the
surface here's the center and we've kind
of plotted the mean number of neighbors
and the standard deviation and there we
can again see that here we have sort of
a wider region where the cells don't
have many neighbors so essentially we
now have a pipeline where we can put in
all these data sets so our colleagues
the biologists they will then produce I
don't know 1020 spheroids we pluck it we
put them into the pipeline and then we
get these graphs out and we can then of
course do that same thing with viewers
that but treated with trucks so then we
can find differences in the cell packing
and see what certain what effect certain
drugs have so to summarize we've
developed this mathematical pipeline so
that we can analyze the the packing of
the nuclei and in the three dimensions
for the segmentation I've used the local
adaptive binarize the laplacian portion
of the watershed then for the future
extraction we've seen we have this list
of replacement rules that is very handy
youth component measurements of
spherical harmonics and these different
types of meshes and for the results we
first of all save them in a notebook and
we also have the density histogram and
the error bar plots and as I said we
this is sort of the basis than to do
drug testing on steroids
so finally I'd like to thank our group
the physical biology group and in
particular of course our boss professor
Stella and then Alex and Penang were
sort of with me in the theoretical team
and I'm also here in the audience and
finally there's one little thing that I
would like to mention is that we do
mathematica courses so we run one-week
introductory courses and they're usually
in March a whole week where we do
mixtures of talks and people can do
their exercises and some of the people
in the audience have already been there
and we also do one-day advanced courses
so of course image analysis and
statistical data analysis are sort of
our main topics at the moment but we're
also thinking of expanding them and they
are open to everyone who would like to
come along so if you're interested you
can either go to our homepage or just
send me an email and then I can keep you
updated on on the next dates and that's
it thank you very much